>> THANKS VERY MUCH.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP UNVEILED
THE DESIGN OF THE PROPOSED
BORDER WALL ON TWITTER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
BUT WILL THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
EVER BE FUNDED?
JOINING US NOW, FREEDOM CAUCUS
CHAIRMAN, CONGRESSMAN MARK
MEADOWS AND JIM JORDAN.
WILL IT EVER BE FUNDED?
>> YES.
REMEMBER, JUST LAST WEEK IN THE
OVAL OFFICE NANCY PELOSI TOLD
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES THERE AREN'T THE VOTES IN
THE HOUSE TO FUND IT.
JUST LAST NIGHT, 217 REPUBLICANS
PROVED HER WRONG AND VOTED TO
PASS A BILL WITH DOLLARS FOR A
BORDER SECURITY WALL.
THIS MAKES GOOD SENSE.
THE ONLY REASON WE'RE GOING TO
BE HEADED TO A SHUTDOWN IS
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO
SUPPORT IT.
>> TRUMP PROMISED IT.
HE HAS TRIED TO DELIVER.
THE HOUSE DELIVERED, BUT THE
SENATE WON'T.
SO IS THIS THE CHUCK SCHUMER
SHUTDOWN?
>> WELL, INDEED, IN JUST AN
HOURS WHEN IT SHUTS DOWN, THE
ONLY PERSON STANDING BETWEEN
REALLY GETTING A DEAL AND NOT
GETTING A DEAL IS CHUCK SCHUMER.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, YOU
MENTIONED PETER DUCEY WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S HIS ENTIRE TEAM THAT HAS
BEEN WORKING ON CAPITOL HILL ALL
DAY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT, MICK
MULVANEY, JARED KUSHNER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ON THE
PHONE THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
HIS DESIRE IS TO NOT SHUT IT
DOWN, BUT IT'S ALSO TO DELIVER
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE A SECURE
BORDER.
AND WE'VE GOT TO DO THAT.
HE'S MADE A PROMISE.
HE'S COMMITTED TO THAT.
I BELIEVE WE'LL GET IT DOWN.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOT A DEAL
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF SCHUMER.
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
FRAMERS DIDN'T WANT.
THEY ARGUED ABOUT HAVING IT.
AND THEY ABANDONED THE IDEA
BECAUSE THEY TRIED IT BEFORE IN
THE ARTICLES OF CONFEDERATION
AND IT LED TO CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTION.
OVER THE LAST DECADES, HUNDREDS
OF PRODUCTIVE BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEFEATED BY THIS ARTIFICIAL
DEVICE CALLED A FILIBUSTER.
ISN'T IT TIME TO END THE
FILIBUSTER FOR EVERYTHING ONCE
AND FOR ALL?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S WHERE
I'M AT.
THAT'S WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S NOT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IT IS A SENATE RULE.
IMAGINE IF THEY KEPT A
FILIBUSTER FOR SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CHANGE THE
RULES FOR SOMETHING THAT
IMPORTANT.
IT SEEMS TO ME WHEN YOUR TALKING
ABOUT OUR NATION'S SECURITY,
BILLING A WALL, WHICH WAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROMISE, IT SEEMS TO
ME THIS IS OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE WHERE WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY SAY, UNITED STATES
SENATE, MAYBE YOU NEED TO CHANGE
THAT SO WE CAN GET THIS DONE.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP PUSHING AND
GET THE WALL DONE.
THE PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO
IT.
HIS TEAM IS WORKING HARD TO
NIGHT TRYING TO GET MEMBERS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW CRITICAL THIS IS
AND ACTUALLY DELIVER FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
>> CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, CRITICS
WOULD SAY, WELL, WAIT A MINUTE,
REPUBLICANS HAVE HAD CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE AND SENATE FOR TWO
YEARS AND THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
THE BETTER PART OF TWO YEARS,
AND YET YOU HAVE FAILED TO
UNDERTAKE COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT WOULD
INCLUDE A BORDER WALL.
SO DOESN'T THE GOP LEADERSHIP,
McCONNELL AND PAUL RYAN AND
OTHERS, BEAR THE LION'S SHARE OF
THE BLAME?
>> THERE'S CERTAINLY ENOUGH
BLAME TO GO AROUND.
PUTTING SOMETHING ON THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK IS WHAT
CONGRESS SHOULD HAVE DONE.
I WILL SAY THIS, THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY MADE A FOUR-PILLAR
OPTION AND IT WAS SCHUMER WHO
SAID NO TO THAT OPTION.
WE SPEND MORE MONEY ON SUGAR
SUBSIDIES THAN WE DO ON BUILDING
A WALL TO SECURE OUR NATION.
I FIND THAT JUST
INCOMPREHENSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE OFFER
AFTER OFFER AFTER OFFER AND BEEN
VERY REASONABLE.
IT IS TIME THAT WE PUT SOMETHING
ON HIS DESK.
I KNOW JIM JORDAN ARE COMMITTED,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE COMMITTED.
>> HE SAID, WAIT A MINUTE, ISN'T
THERE ANOTHER WAY?
WE HAVE A $4.4 TRILLION ANNUAL
BUDGET, $1 TRILLION OF WHICH IS
DISCRETIONARY.
SURELY THE PRESIDENT CAN GRAB $5
BILLION OF IN THAT AND USE IT
WITHOUT SPECIFIC AUTHORIZATION
TO START CONSTRUCTION.
>> WELL, HE CAN, BUT HERE'S THE
INTERESTING THING.
HE CAN BUT I KNOW ALL YOUR
VIEWERS KNOW THAT HE GETS SUED
OVER EVERYTHING.
AND THE MINUTE THAT HE DOES
THAT, HE'S GOING TO GET SUED.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET SOME
LIBERAL JUDGE IN CALIFORNIA TO
SAY IT WON'T WORK.
LISTEN, WE WOULD CERTAINLY
SUPPORT SOME OF THOSE
UNOBLIGATED FUNDS GOING THAT
WAY, BUT IT'S REALLY INCUMBENT
ON CONGRESS TO DO THEIR JOB.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO GETTING IT
DONE.
>> SO YOU'VE GOT FOUR DAYS
REALLY BECAUSE GOVERNMENT
WORKERS AREN'T GOING TO WORK
SATURDAY, SUNDAY, MONDAY.
THEY HAVE THE DAY OFF, THE
HOLIDAY.
SO YOU'VE GOT FOUR DAYS.
WHAT CAN BE DONE?
>> WELL, WE'VE GOT TO JUST KEEP
PUSHING AND MAKING THE ARGUMENT.
MARK IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE NEED TO APPROPRIATE DOLLARS.
$1.6 BILLION IS NOT GOING TO CUT
IT.
IT'S GOT TO BE MORE MONEY THAN
THAT.
THE BIG THING I THINK WE HAVE TO
GET THROUGH IS DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
BE LESS FOCUSED ON STOPPING THE
PRESIDENT AND MORE FOCUSED ON
HELPING THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
STOPPING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LET'S JUST FOCUS ON WHAT'S GOOD
FOR THE COUNTRY.
EVERYONE KNOWS WE'LL HAVE LESS
PROBLEMS IF WE SECURE THE BORDER
AND BUILD THE BORDER SECURITY
WALL.
WE KNOW WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE US.
THIS IS WHY THEY PUT DONALD
TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE TO DELIVER IT.